hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar inspiring credibility the
benefits of automation in experimental
research i am marie stone of lab roots
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab routes and brought to
you by leica biosystems to learn more
visit leica biosystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
april shrank hacker
edd msod cg
ascpcm life sciences marketing leader at
leica biosystems
april you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for that kind introduction
hello everyone and thank you for
attending this talk about inspiring
credibility
the benefits of automation in
experimental research
i am april shank hacker and i am the
life science marketing leader at like a
biosystem
as a certified cytogenetic research
specialist i have spent most of my
career on the bench working in
translational research assay design and
development
in today's presentation we will talk
about the importance of building
credibility into your research
we will discuss reproducibility in terms
of the three r's
reproducibility
repeatability and reclicability
we will help define what they mean
and how they influence research studies
finally we will share a few tips and
tricks about how researchers can
leverage automation and inspire
confidence in results
as we talked about earlier if you have
any questions please add them to the
chat and we will have time to dig into
them at the end of the presentation
great let's jump into it
a recent nature paper shared results
from a survey of over 1500 researchers
in which they questioned the
reproducibility in research
the results were startling
percent of respondees reported being
unable to report
reproduce
another scientist experiment
and more than fifty percent reported
being unable to reproduce their own
i for sure have experienced both of
these predicaments during my research
life have you
i bet each of you has one particular
experience experiment that if i handed
you the microphone you could still tell
us in vivid detail about all the times
you reran that essay
for some reason you should just never
get it to work quite the same way
and for me
it created an unsettling crisis of
confidence in the reliability of
research
but hold on to that thought
we will decode some ways to inspire
credibility in research as we go forward
in the presentation
as we know there are many ways to think
about reproducibility as there are
branches of science
but be careful
not all terms about reproducibility are
created equally
a few key publications were instrumental
in helping researchers define and refine
what reproducibility means
and how we can apply it
marina a barbara at the george
washington university published
terminologies for reproducible research
to help us grapple with the conflicting
definitions of what researchers and
publishers use to describe what
reproducibility is
and how is interpreted within the
different sciences
the key idea
is that the definitions mean different
things to different groups
research research typically classifies
reproducible results using a decision
tree
either a
authors do not distinguish between the
words reproduce and replicate
or b
the terms are used distinctly and are
clarified with sub-categorization
roof b1 uses reproducibility
where the original researcher data
regenerates the results
and group b2 collects new data to arrive
at the same result as the previous study
and refers to this as replicability or
the ability to repeat a study
the federation of american societies for
experimental biology published
recommendations targeted at biomedical
and biological research providing
definitions that fall squarely into b2
so let's talk about we how we can use
the three r's
reproducibility repeatability and
replicability to inspire credibility and
research
as we discussed reproducibility has
similar or nearly identical results
using comparable materials and
methodologies by independent researchers
for example looking at the liver
sections to the right
each was generated from the same exact
block but seen at six different labs
we can easily see significant
variability in the scanning intensity
and differentiation in each image
lack of optimization of process can lead
to difficulties with reproducibility
repeatability measures the variation in
measurements taken by other researchers
under the same conditions or settings
in this image to the left we can see
several different tissues stained with
similar consistency in each row
using automation can impact
repeatability
reflectability is the ability to
duplicate
or repeat a prior result using the same
source materials and methodologies
it is important to think about that when
you're referring to repeating the
results of a specific experiment rather
than an entire study
with the increased focus on radar and
reproducibility the national institute
of health
and publishing groups nature and science
held a workshop with journal editors in
basic and pre-clinical science journals
to investigate how to ensure rigor and
reproducibility in research publications
a few details included having a good
research design and elements such as
complete methods and materials section
replicate studies and range of
conditions and data reporting were
identified as the framework for what
good looks like
following these guidelines can help
others to repeat the experiment and
speed therapies
now that we've talked about what
reproducibility is
let's turn to how we can use it as a
framework and what tools such as
automation
can impact inspiring credibility in
research
i propose automation has four supporting
pillars or ways for potentially
impacting research the first is
automation helps to generate
trustworthiness in research
it also offers reproducibility through
workflow optimization and
standardization
automation of workflows through
instrument processing protocols
and together
we significantly inspire confidence in
results
watch for the color-coded icons
throughout the remainder of the
presentation to highlight the potential
for automation's impact on research
let us define a few keywords that we
will be talking more about when we talk
about reproducibility
trustworthiness
is the credible transferable confirmable
and dependable
optimization is
operational efficiency and
standardization of procedure and
confidence is how sure you can be
of research
some current methods rely heavily on
manual processes that carry an inherent
risk for inter-operator process step
variability
handwriting identifiers on slides can
can be transposed or illegible
i might fit my slides for 32 seconds
while my co-worker might get faster or
smaller
my thigh might sit in hemotoxin for
three minutes while the next round might
sit for five minutes while the phone
rings
we may have all experienced some of
these examples in our daily lab length
and know it's these tiny hard to control
for nuances of manual process that can
significantly impact results
automation renews human variability
which optimizes your workflow and can
lead to credibility in your research
keeping the four pillars
of using automation to inspire
credibility in mind
i'm going to invite you to rethink some
of the current methods perhaps
and share a few tips and tricks about
how automation can impact research
remember how variable our examples of
manual tasks in the lab could be
automation lowers the inter-variability
of different runs over different dates
and intra-assay variability providing
consistency between slides within one
run for
example the key is
automation offers
confidence and consistency over repeated
ones which can positively impact
researches building trustworthiness
reproducibility and confidence
manual process has variations along the
workflow
for instance each scientist or
technologist has individual processing
ways that even the best sop can't
control for
other factors such as time and
temperature can flux in manual processes
and even reagent preparation can
introduce variability
we all know that scales are not created
equal either
[Music]
the image to the left is the same
section of tissue stained on different
days showing variability between
staining runs
automation can offer building
consistency by monitoring sample
conditions and applications
in fact impacting research in terms of
reproducibility
automation supports reproducibility and
drives confidence by completely removing
manual processing
and providing results through consistent
handling of materials time after time
looking down the image columns at the
right
you can see how automation has
consistent results on different runs in
different tissues
slide one can be equally assessed to
eight hundred
and eight hundred to sixteen hundred
providing and reviewing protocol metrics
is a critical success factor identified
as a part of good research design
automation provides onboard metrics
capture for producing or repeating
reliable results
examples include protocol specifics
run times
specific specimen identifiers
reagent monitoring and problem loans
providing accurate and complete
documentation in publications and in
your daily work help in supporting
trustworthiness and build confidence in
research
the use of automation can improve
efficiencies
optimize labor-intensive and error-prone
manual processes within the workflow
to help you re-imagine this idea
observe your current workflow over a few
days
benchmark the current standard
processing times and the number and
complexity of manual steps
no potentials for intra operational and
inter operational variability
by minimizing the human variable and
removing opportunities for human error
automation encourages reproducibility
repeatability and replicability
and inspires credibility
i remember furiously scribbling notes
into my lab notebook trying to capture
every critical detail of the
experimental steps in my proto of my
protocol as you can see marie curie had
the same process backwards when she was
discovering radium
today
automated instrumentation can be your
partner in producing and tracking
critical data such as recording process
steps during a run what reagents you use
how long and time in terms of how long
did things run for and temperatures
also documenting protocol parameter data
optimization by automation by automating
your workflow can add consistency and
reproducibility to your research
why optimize workflow through automation
foundations first
automation can be a powerful tool in the
lab
but be careful
think about reproducibility in terms of
a copy machine
they don't understand what they're
copying
they just copy
optimized workflows through automation
can replicate quality results
but
non-optimized workflow using automation
will replicate suboptimal results
consistently
we've talked about a few frameworks for
inspiring credibility and research and a
few tips and tricks for how automation
can impact research
as a wrap-up here are three easy steps
to inspire confidence and credibility
first
reproducibility of results over time
second optimize optimization of
automation for optims for operational
efficiency
and third
and most one of the most important is
trustworthiness
and not just within the research you're
doing but also within the field as an
author that you're providing to other
other researchers
your affiliation the universe or your
institution that you're publishing on
behalf of
and the publisher themselves the
journals and
that you're working and writing through
i wanted to share our last resource with
you this is called knowledge pathway
knowledge pathway is our educational
portal at leica by assistance where you
can go and read content and learn more
about
building confidence in your research
thank you for the gifts of your time and
attention and i will
thank you april for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what things should i look to include
when thinking about publishing in terms
of reproducibility
thank you well that's a great question
so some of the things noted from the nih
workshop were a focus on rigor and
reproducibility such as developing a
good research design and including
complete materials and methods sections
also um a descriptive statement of the
replicate studies and accuracy of
reporting data would be
really great in just in the design of
that
thank you
next question
how does automation support ways to
potentially impact research
yeah um so i really like to use the four
pillars that we talked about
uh
by building trustworthiness and
generating credible and transferable
methods
optimizing the workflow by having the
standard standardized instrument process
protocols that make the data really easy
and reproducible and by doing all those
things it really inspires confidence in
the results
great
next question
how can automation help with reducing
variability in my experiments
i would say that automation really
removes that human variable that comes
with a manual process when you're doing
your samples
it offers consistency run after run and
it really lowers the inter variability
between runs over different days and
even the interact to intra-assay
variability within one run
great it looks like we have time for one
more question
how can open source hardware help
that's a really good question i think
there's lots of options that are now
available to us the more automation
becomes prevalent i think one of the
great things that you can do in terms of
open source hardware is to really go
back to your uh your
your application specialist and ask them
how that might apply to your application
great well thank you again april for
your time today in your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor leica biosystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye